I want to start practicing an instrument
oh yeah I want to play drums okay but do
you want it like are you trying to just
hit drums or are you trying to like
learn I want three drums I want to get
very into it talk about like numbers
like you know like oh there's a three
free to music or [ __ ] what else that's
an eight because I'm a musical genius
okay yeah all right I just want I just
need to learn just give my wrist loose
really I'm a natural but I just need to
get the muscle memory going you know
because most beats you know are like
four four eight ages but then when you
start [ __ ] with [ __ ] like one two
three one one that's when things get
weird that was like can you get down
with that that was as far as class goes
oh I didn't progress there most pop
music is like whoa one you know sing
along so I know it cuz then what give me
a familiar song so I know it I'll beat
that [ __ ] with a bat
I'll beat that [ __ ] with a bad that's
like a four for eight so I don't do a
Juke song that's right but that's
classic like a house that's classic but
that's like give a pop song that songs
to come here this Michael Jackson yeah
yeah
I was I wasn't you know I wasn't here
but you know I thought you would get it
off of the melody yeah so yeah I'm take
a drum and class